[Music]
what would make minimalism a cult the
reason i asked this question
is because
i could see how it could very easily
become if ryan and i had the desire to
turn it into a cult we we definitely we
could do
a benevolent version of nexium yes um
because there are certainly the roots in
in mysticism and buddhism and simple
living and
minimalist art and architecture sort of
all sort of combined together to make
this thing and we've had you know
millions of people see our netflix films
and so we we have this ability to
attract a certain number of people but i
think the biggest difference for me and
the reason it couldn't be a cult for us
not that it couldn't be for others is i
don't want to be with groups of people
i am like the the most sort of
introverted the only people i hang out
with regularly or my wife my daughter
and my best friend here and then the
group of people that's in this room or
the other people on our team like
jess or emma's not here today but like i
spend more time with the people i work
directly with but even them i i feel
like oh i don't want power over them by
the way he still doesn't like any of us
i never claimed to know he loves us
though but isn't it funny though that in
the age of the internet so many cults
can form uh without like the cult
leader's consent because they're like
parasocial you know i think of celebrity
stands um like there are really zealous
fan cults that form around certain
celebrities and public figures that the
celebrity themselves has like almost
like a toxic relationship with or is
like oh you're acting too radical i wish
you wouldn't you know cause drama in my
life this way or maybe the relationship
you know there they aren't controlling
that group they're like a monster that's
they've that they've built themselves
because people seek community and tribes
so fundamentally that you know you can
have this totally parasocial cult i also
think of you know certain people on
social media who maybe never imagined
they would blow up and you know have a
social media quote-unquote cult of their
own and it sort of you know metastasizes
without them
intentionally creating that you know
so so if i look at the characteristics
of minimalism it would turn into a cult
if
we wanted to wield power over people i
think that's the first thing that i can
think of a few reasons well i've been
thinking about this um well i think it
would be very cultish of you
to um and this is totally antithetical
to how you two operate but if you
instantly created this really severe us
versus them dichotomy yeah like you
cannot casually participate in
minimalism if you don't do xyz you're
not a minimalist you're not one of us
you're the enemy right and i've been
thinking about minimalism sort of um
comparing it in my mind to to veganism
because yeah um yeah like i was i was
vegan for a long time i still eat you
know mostly plant-based but whatever i
may be like 80 vegan
and i got into veganism vegans hate when
you say something like that i know i
know it is it is quite cultish um and i
hate to say that and i'll talk about
that in a second but i initially got
into veganism because i was inspired by
the vegan youtube community
and this was during a time when um
high carb low fat veganism was very
trendy it was like a lot of fruitarians
and people who you know
treated like healthy fats and oils like
they were the devil
and if you weren't
like and of course no one alive is a
hundred percent vegan like never
encounter something that doesn't use an
animal product it's like almost
impossible
um even your fruit has bugs in it
yeah right yeah how many moles had to
die to like yeah to get that spinach how
many bees had to suffer for you to eat
those blueberries you know you can
there's like the slippery slope argument
that you can
follow down that rabbit hole but um but
yeah i remember you know feeling like i
never met any of these vegan influencers
that were having such a strong effect on
me but their rhetoric and their um
extremism
and i'm talking about that in the
context of this us them dichotomy was so
burned into my brain that as i was
living my everyday life and grocery
shopping and like looking at a bag of
sandwich bread at the office and being
starving and being like i want to make a
piece of toast but that has a speck of
whey in it and whey is like an animal
product and i can't have that because
this social media influencer who i've
never even met and doesn't even know me
would think of me as a bad vegan um
and you know over the years i've grown
older and i've you know constructed my
own sense of identity and i've realized
that you can have more balance and it's
not always realistic here's the thing is
that my my partner has become vegetarian
and i have become more vegetarian and
statistically if more of the world just
ate a little bit less meat that would be
way better than like point one percent
of the world being a hundred percent
vegan you know what i mean but i'm sort
of thinking like
minimalism and veganism have some
similarities in that you know if
everybody was perfectly minimalist like
yes that would be good for the planet
like the planet would benefit the people
might suffer psychologically you know
depending on who was having power over
them um but ultimately like veganism and
minimalism are going for something good
um something objectively good not
something subjectively good like some
you know sky daddy will reward you later
like i think we can all agree that you
know doing things to minimize our
consumerism or to minimize our meat
consumption is is helpful for the planet
but you can so easily take that
objectively good thing
and twist it so that it almost like
works counter-intuitively because nobody
can be 100 minimalist nobody can be 100
vegan and eventually there's going to be
a breaking point
yeah yeah and i think there's there's no
prescription with me and ryan like even
jokingly in our last book love people
use things there are these 16 rules for
living with less but we even talk about
how they're not actually rules like we
don't have any they're they're
adjustable and so like what's the
punishment if you break one like there
is nothing exactly yeah we don't take
away your minimalist certificate yeah
you get this fellowship we shun you the
other minimalist friends of yours can't
talk to you anymore that's how it felt
when i was under again that completely
parasocial influence of the vegan
community i still think that like
veganism is fantastic and i like try to
abide by a vegan mentality as much as
possible but i think that us them
dichotomy um and some of the buzzwords
and such that that are used to enforce
that um can can be one of the most
destructive aspects i don't think we're
talking about cult versus nautical i
mean
after reading amanda's book i think
minimalism is a bit of a cult it is
cultic
so the question isn't like how like what
what steps could josh and i do like to
really make this a cult
the question that you're really asking
is what steps can we do to make this a
very unhealthy cult exactly because as i
was saying on the on our on the public
podcast um that you know the word cult
itself is not enough to illuminate the
dangers and risks that are on the table
because so many groups could be
considered cult seeing as this word is
so subjective that you need to be like a
little bit more specific in what you're
talking about and something can be
cultish without being bad yeah
absolutely did you enjoy this video if
so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free